i think you're going to find this very
interesting over the weekend
there was a so-called million maga march
in washington dc i guess in support of
donald trump
losing i don't even know i guess to make
the case that donald trump actually won
it's very unclear what they were arguing
but despite
donald trump's press secretary kaylee
mckennany
claiming on twitter that there were more
than a million people there
a more realistic estimate is like 80 000
maybe 100 thousand people still a lot of
people
but um not a million and fox news
covered this march and as they are
covering the march and doing an
interview
a pro-trump protester holding up a sign
so vile and so disgusting popped up on
screen
and you actually hear the fox news
anchor pause when it pops up and mention
the the sign this is fox anchor eric
shawn
you will hear him uh a sort of a
it gives him pause when the sign comes
up the sign for those who aren't
watching
says coming for blacks and indians first
welcome to the new world order take a
look take a listen to this
i've talked to republican party leaders
about this i've said to them
you're going to be in office a long time
after president trump
is the republican party is going to long
outlast
all of us uh aren't you concerned about
that so
so that's what somebody's going to have
to convince
the president of the president isn't a
long-term thinker they're going to have
to convince him
that it's in his own interest and that
is what he responds to
like what is in his interest
we just saw a very disturbing sign it
said coming for blacks and indians
welcome to the new world order i mean
who the hell knows
you know what type of what people have
and what they say on these things but
what do the republicans tell you so
first of all
that really is the type of stuff that
was running rampant at this
absolutely vile event now you know what
i'm going to say right
okay the sign was sick enough for the
fox anchor to mention it
but not sick enough for it to be
denounced he reports on the sign like
you would mention
oh there there's a food cart hold up
hold on a second
hold on a second ted there's a food cart
offering two for one pretzels during the
rally that that's quite an aggressive
sale
it's very matter of fact the sign is
coming for blacks and indians first
that's the sign and you don't denounce
it
the only upside i can think of is that
republicans and these trumpists
are being more honest and upfront now
with their beliefs right there
they're just saying it out loud right on
their sign instead of pretending that
this is not all
just racism and xenophobia and hate so
it's a little bit more transparency i
will give them that and if you go over
to the new enclave of the pro-trump
right on the internet
it's called parlor it's filled with this
stuff
they've gone you know full mask off
figuratively and literally given the
pandemic they've gotten full mask off
on parlor it is everywhere but i would
go even further
let me go back to the fox news thing for
a second
fox news anchor eric shawn sees a sign
that's wacky it's wacky enough to
mention it
but apparently it's not wacky enough for
him to denounce it
understand that fox news is partially to
blame for whipping people
up to the point where they're willing to
be seen in public with such a sign
fox did not create racism trump did not
create racism but they've whipped it up
and
fired people up and coalesced them and
fox should really own this behavior
understand
i i would call it irony but it feels
like if you call it irony
it's not serious enough fox news has
been lying to people for so long
that trump supporters are now thinking
even fox news has become a liberal enemy
that's how dumb the country has gotten
this is the natural end result
fox news has radicalized its viewers to
such a degree
that they are now too radical to even
watch fox news at least during the day i
guess they still find some
comfort in the evening hours understand
that
think about that to understand how
depraved this situation has become
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman